In this lesson, you'll learn how to
optimize your pages for different screen
sizes, including the difference between
CSS and device-independent pixels,
and how to choose the right sizes for
your elements.
>> And at the end of the lesson,
you'll build the mobile
version of the hometown site.
Now, when I'm working on my sites,
sometimes I notice that content seems to
flow off the page or I have to pinch and
zoom to see anything.
What's going on here?
>> Well besides your CSS which
could use a little bit of work,
the biggest problem is that you don't
have the viewport set properly.
The viewport defines the area of
the screen that the browser can
render content to.
Here, let me show you an example.
In my laptop, I've sized the browser
window to 800 pixels wide,
which makes my view port 800 pixels.
If I expand the width,
the view port size changes, and
now I have a view port
width of 1000 pixels.
>> All right,
well that seems simple enough.
But not all displays have
the same pixel density right.
>> Right.
>> Like what about something like
your Chromebook pixel display.
>> Right.
Well the Chromebook pixel display,
tells me that it's got a width
of 2,560 pixels by 1,700 pixels.
But when I make the browser
window the full width.
And ask for the view port width.
It tells me its only 1280 pixels wide.
>> Wait.
Not the full 2560.
>> Nope.
Not at all.
>> Hm.
Well not all pixels were created equal.
Were they?
>> Exactly.
A pixel isn't always a pixel.